[Aplausos]
hola yo soy andrés y quiero contarte un
sueño mi más grande sueño actualmente es
crear conciencia e impactar a miles de
millones de personas en el mundo con
dice de animada llamada global un lugar
luego es un proyecto que apenas está en
su primera fase de desarrollo está en
pañales y es como un 29 y he aprendido
muchísimas cosas a través del desarrollo
de esta serie cosas esenciales en mi
vida y cosas trascendentales como el
trabajo en equipo y compartir tus sueños
pero ahora que ya conoces más grandes
sueños quiero que todos bueno todos
buenos y todos me digan si alguien
actualmente tiene un sueño que quiere
cumplir que levante la mano mantengan la
cabeza mantengan ese sueño si tienen uno
que quiere cumplir y con la mano en alto
quiero que volviera a ver a su alrededor
también y creo que la gran mayoría si no
es que todos tenemos un sueño que
queremos cumplir y es súper natural
porque los sueños son inherentes al ser
humano pero usualmente nos contamos
historias limitantes en nuestra cabeza
de que no podemos crear nuestros sueños
no podemos cumplirlos y quiero
ejemplificar eso con algo que dice
nuestra queridísima llamada real
academia de la lengua española y cuando
estoy leyendo los significados de la
radio sobre el sueño hubo lo que me
llamó mucho la atención y es que para la
radio de un sueño es una cosa que carece
de realidad o fundamento y en especial
proyecto deseo esperanza sin
probabilidad de realizarse y está bien
contundente esa definición pero también
bien peligrosa porque notamos como desde
el lenguaje empezamos a limitarnos como
seres creadores en este universo
y a mí me pasó créanme que yo mucho
tiempo creí que mis sueños no merecían
ser escuchados que no debía de seguirlos
incluso realmente pensaba que los niños
más anhelados eran solamente de sus
esperanzas y probabilidad de realizarse
en este mundo
pero creo que no es casualidad que yo
esté aquí con ustedes hablando de sueños
porque desde pequeña siempre es un niño
super soñador y mi sueño más grande
siento este pequeñito puede ser súper yo
jugaba de pequeño me vestía como mis
superiores afición favoritos y ellos me
inspiran muchísima trayectoria en mi
mente y que con esta cruz era pueblos
para enrolar a mis primos o enrolar a
mis amigos y jugar estas maravillosas
historias crecían en mi mente gracias a
la inspiración que me daba
yo en realidad le aprendido a través de
historias y personajes memorables
durante toda mi vida y me ha llamado
mucho la atención y me siguen llamando
mucho la atención todas las series
animadas las películas animadas me
encanta la animación pero que en
realidad
me gustan mucho los personajes que
atravesaban por diferentes facetas y que
iban evolucionando psicológicamente y
también iban evolucionando personalmente
esto joseph campbell le llama el viaje
del héroe dentro económico dentro del
viaje del héroe eso también dice que el
personaje principal en la narrativa de
tu historia requiere de atravesar por
diferentes estadías para que pueda
trascender eventualmente y cumplir su
meta en la vida o en esta historia
y dentro de todas esas historias
memorables viajes del héroe hay un anime
que me encanta el pequeño me sigue
gustando muchísimo y creo que muchos
ustedes lo conocen lo habrán visto no
escucho hablar de él y se llama dragon
fall trouble creado por akira toriyama
es increíble genio nipón
tiene un personaje principal llamado
grupo igual tiene una técnica y me creo
a mi soccer en cuenta en muchas cosas la
técnica se llama definitiva esta técnica
consiste en que el levantaba las manos y
en el último recurso que utilizaba eran
todas las manos para crear una esfera de
energía y le pedí al universo de los
seres vivos que le brindaron un poco de
su energía para poder vencer al mal
y que en ese momento cumplieron el sueño
más grande que tenían que era salvar al
universo y cuidar a sus seres queridos
para extraer esa técnica yo vi que hasta
el ser más poderoso necesitaba mostrarse
vulnerable ante el universo y pedir
apoyo a todos incluso confiar en que su
equipo no iba a la ciudad y que iban a
incluso dar la vida por él para lograr
en conjunto ese sueño en el awd era
salvar al universo
y estos personajes junto con coco y
muchísimos pasaron tantas cosas pero mis
sueños fueron evolucionando y pasé de
ser un pequeño niño que se vestía de
personajes
algo que llamó pubertad y adolescencia
que todos vivimos
y como el progreso porque yo quería ser
súper famoso con una banda de rock y lo
que hace mi primer examen en la
universidad así que pensé creo que este
es el momento para que tienes y hagas tu
banda de rock diversión entonces lo
hicimos nos llevamos the night y
obviamente no nos hicimos para nada
famosos pero aprendí mucho de esto y
aprendí a confiar porque no importaba
que fuera en un festival de la escuela
de la preparatoria o en un festival de
algún pueblito tú le querías confiar en
que la banda iba a llegar
e iba a dar el mejor show de su vida
pero realmente también este sueño lo
solté y entré a la universidad de la
comunicación y en comunicación comprendí
que me encanta no está de acuerdo en el
quinto semestre para estar enfrente una
cámara actualmente me sigue gustando
muchísimo y mi sueño más grande lo
cambié porque es muy bueno cambiar los
sueños evolucionar es muy importante
porque hace nosotros evolucionamos los
sueños que tienen ir cambiando entonces
debería ser el conductor más famoso
el mundo y no de bebé pero con eso
comprendí y genere en mi vida en casa
para entrar a un programa de televisión
el cual pasaban todas las mañanas a las
nueve de la mañana por efecto del
llamado por fin y salíamos a nivel
nacional estuvo bien divertido y pude
estar en la alfombra roja del primer
festival del cine que se hizo aquí en
toluca conociéndola me trabajo muchas
cosas muy gratas y un aprendizaje muy
importante que fue saber que las cosas
en equipo bajan para un bien mayor no
importa el individualismo en este
programa importaba que el programa
saliera bien y enternece sobre ese sueño
porque me quise ir a estudiar a españa
ocasión de la programación más grande se
convirtió en querer conocer el mundo y
allí fue donde empecé a impulsar mi
canal entonces fueron dos sueños en
conjuntos hay como una trenza donde
empecé a subir más vídeos de viajes mi
canal empezó a crecer conoce muchísimas
partes del mundo es súper divertido y
gracias a esto me genere el trabajo que
actualmente hago que soy director de
vídeos en una empresa llamada munitis en
la cual yo me encargo de crear todo el
contenido del canal de youtube y
actualmente nos acaban de reconocer en
2019 en el bullyng education por el
contenido que tenemos y por el modelo de
negocios que se está generando
gracias a este canal y ustedes estarán
preguntando ya y antes dónde demonios
está la serie
hoy estoy viva como una ola como un
pequeño tsunami
eventualmente iba creciendo allí en
paralelo de todo desde españa y otra vía
esta idea y cuando regresó regreso con
emociones super encontradas
me encuentro perdido no sé quién soy
y comienza a escribir después de una
semana haber pisado méxico y así surge
cuando la llevo con un desarrollo de un
año y medio yo solo y eventualmente se
empiezan a sumar más personas
y aquí comprendí que muchísimas cosas se
me han pasado para llegar hasta y
requerido pasarme porque todo es
perfecto como es y yo comienza en el
sueño con el cual levantaron la mano y
que piensen todos los caminos y
posibilidades que existen para que
puedan llegar al una vez que tengan ese
número quiero decirles que si está
pensando en un número completo se acaban
de mentir brutalmente porque para llegar
de un punto alto y sólo piso ahora a un
punto ver que su sueño hay una infinidad
de posibilidades para lograrlo y yo sé
que parece una locura que no haya pasos
establecidos o preestablecidos para que
sigamos un paso a uno paso 2 paso 3
omiso no está cumplido no nos sale
parece una locura pero más bien como
dice 'la se procura es hacer lo mismo
una y otra vez esperando obtener
resultados diferentes así que me atreví
a hacer las cosas diferentes una y otra
vez a casi una me resultó que fue
reorganizar mis sueños compartirlos y
acercar a las personas a decirles oye
tengo una historia que quiero contar
pero yo no sé dibujar yo no sé animar no
sé si a muchas cosas
y ahí fue cuando comprendí que hay
personas que te van a escuchar nunca
sale se siente a escuchar no sabemos si
la mitad de este teatro tiene el mismo
sueño que tú o que tú
tal vez con ellos podrías hacer un gran
equipo y comparar y convertirlo en
realidad
gracias a comprender esto y escuchar una
vez con mi profe de producción
audiovisual
en una frase que dijo arquímedes que yo
estoy muy de acuerdo con él desde un
punto de apoyo y moveré al mundo y todos
requerimos de apoyo alguna vez en
nuestra vida y está bien a veces
solamente necesitas una persona a tu
lado para crear cosas inimaginables
después de todo esto y de compartir mis
sueños trabajar en equipo
todos involucrados en lugar lo logramos
algo increíble fue un logro personal muy
particular al inicio y muy grato porque
más de 300 proyectos de a nivel
latinoamérica el cual no fue
seleccionado para hacer uno de los 24
participantes en el busca me detuve en
2019 hecho por pixel
aquí vienen grandes ejecutivos
productores escritores series animadas
como en este caso tengo pis y besan
borges y demás
dentro de este aprendizaje
descubrimos que nos faltaba bastante
trabajo que hacer pero nos alentó a
seguir con este sueño y ahora ya no era
un sueño único ahora ellas como todos
los que estaban colaborando personas muy
talentosas estaban muy felices por haber
logrado esto y ahora estaban a mi lado
compartiendo este sueño yo no ve a mi
equipo atrás de mí los veo junto a mí
navegando en esta nave espacial hacia en
la inmensidad del universo de los sueños
navegando hace nuestro juntos
y es bien complicado no es complicado
más bien es complejo
es complejo de trabajar en equipo porque
actualmente
el mundo piensa de una forma muy curiosa
del carpe diem al cual te invita a la
individualidad te invita a que lo es en
todas las redes sociales en todos los
lugares de las personas en su teléfono
pueden ver en el timeline que van a
encontrar una infinidad de frases como
yo quiero que voy a viajar yo yo yo y es
muy importante estar completos 12
porque obviamente las formas esenciales
como el amor no puedes amar sin amarte a
ti mismo no puedes dar lo que no tienes
los invitamos tanto el vídeo mismo que
olvidamos muchas cosas y es que nos da
miedo nos da miedo no compartir no
trabajar en equipo porque porque no
podemos controlar nada de lo que está
afuera hay mucho causa poder hay un
montón de desastre y sólo puedes
controlar tu participación en la vida en
toda cubierta yo sé que da muchísimo
miedo pero tras aprender a través del
caos es algo opcional
el perdón no es opcional más bien es
obligatorio aprender a través del cauce
decidir aprender a través de virtudes es
algo yo creo que muy salva
y algo que en realidad podrías cambiar y
tener miedo de tener confianza
aprender a través de ser gentil ser
amoroso de comprender de ayudarse
y es bien curioso porque esto
actualmente es muy valorado por las
empresas se les llama soft scripts o
habilidades blandas todas las empresas
actuales están buscando mucho esto en
sus empleados porque porque nos aprendo
un libro de texto
yo lo aprendí y lo aprendí en la
universidad y creo que fue un pilar
fundamental de universidad para ello la
miel del conocimiento de las habilidades
blandas las aprendí sin querer queriendo
como diría chespirito
por mis profesores más entrañables con
una maestra de creación literaria que me
dio el valor para saber que todo lo
festivo merece ser leído
y sobre todo las jardineras de mi
facultad en universidad compartiendo con
mis amigos escuchando siendo escuchado y
viendo que todos nos parecemos tanto en
todos los sueños y anhelos que tenemos
y
aquí el tema es que cuando empiezas a
trabajar estas virtudes estos
sorpresivos aprendes y comprendes y
kaisen cuenta de que también requiere
hacer acciones comprometidas para
comenzar a crear tus sueños y va a haber
precios bien caros a pagar
no sólo monetarios va a haber uno bien
importante y es el tiempo el tiempo es
nuestra única moneda de cambio con
nuestro universo para crear cosas y el
tiempo es el único recurso no renovable
que tenemos porque el tiempo no vuelve
jamás
pero en cuenta de muchas cosas cuando
ves el tiempo esto es la única manera de
cambio
descubres que los sueños se cultivan
que tienen tiempo el que el esfuerzo que
en construcción
no plantas un árbol de naranjas un día y
al otro estás disfrutando de un
delicioso jugo por la mañana tiene
tiempo y la naturaleza incluso no lo
dice no hay inmediatez en la vida no hay
inmediatez aquí solo en las pantallas
que tienen
y caer en cuenta a veces creo que
olvidamos muy seriamente que si el kit
si recibimos tanto tiempo para crear
nuestros sueños por qué no compartirlo
con la ya disfrutar del viaje ir
acompañados está bien chulo de verdad y
en serio que no pasa nada si en algún
momento requiere levantar las manos y
pedir al universo ya todos los
ejercicios que tiene un peso energía
para lograr sus sueños no está mal
a veces se nos olvida o queremos olvidar
que no sólo compartimos este teatro o
esta ciudad o este país compartimos todo
un universo y allá afuera hay una
biología universal de la cual tú y yo
somos parte hay un cosmos infinito al
cual todos pertenecemos
y realmente cuentan sus sueños
verbalicen los concreten los a través de
acciones comprometidas y fijan su
historia y sus sueños a través de la
gentileza y van a descubrir los
brillantes que pueden ser
pero que una vez que comienzan a soñar
en voz alta descubran que todo puede
cambiar
porque ahora me puedo presentar de una
manera muy diferente
hola yo soy andrés
y ven que quiero escuchar tus sueños un
honor gracias
[Aplausos]